Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so everyone's
freaking out about the episode 8 title the
last Jedi wondering if they're going to off
Luke Skywalker there a couple big reasons
why think that they will and a couple reasons
why I think that they won't.
So I'll try to address both sides of that
argument and they also teased a little bit
about the future of the Skywalker family relative
to the saga films, so I'll explain that at
the end of the video there is a new round
of the Star Wars giveaway it's for IMAX gift
certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so the Star
Wars people are always intentionally vague
about the new films.
Just to try and hold back as many details
as possible but based on the trajectory of
the new films in the future of Star Wars movies
in general after the saga you can make a few
guesses on what's going to be happening with
the Skywalker family, especially in this new
trilogy but there couple big reasons why they
would kill off Luke Skywalker in this next
film in a couple why they would not so try
to address things on both sides, so number
one reasons why they would the title the last
Jedi hints at him in a couple the international
posters.
The language was made singular mail.
So even if arRey were in training to be a
Jedi.
It would have been plural in all the posters
all around the world, but the problem is is
that they were trying to be ambiguous with
the title that they want people to wonder
always Jedi plural or is it singular.
That's the whole idea, but it's really hard
to do that in all the languages around the
world.
And even if you go by the episode seven title
crawl, which names Luke the last of the Jedi,
he was the last of the Jedi before the force
awakening in Rey.
So even though the evidence does point to
Luke being the last of the Jedi there still
number of arguments that you can make it.
It's a plural meeting.
But number two Luke Skywalker is the de facto
Obi-Wan Kenobi of this new trilogy his relationship
with Rey is almost the exact same relationship
he had with Obi-Wan Kenobi in the original
trilogy why's and master teaching new recruit
about the ways of the force, Luke and Rey
are very similar characters but that the exact
same he required like a little more prodding
from OB one when they were on tattooing come
with me to alter on Luke learn the ways of
the force know I can't do that about the harvest
about all these responsibilities after pushing
Luke over the precipice teaching him a little
bit about the force.
He became a force ghost himself.
And even though they've recontextualize what
it means to be a force ghost with the rules
of being a force ghost is he still went away
leaving Luke Skywalker on his own and there
was a lot of adventures that Luke went on
between episode four and Empire strikes back,
that they deal with in the marvel comics that
they started publishing again, so if you want
to read about those they pick up like right
after episode four, Luke has all kinds of
run-ins with Vader before he meets him in
battle during Empire strikes back completely
recontextualizing that final moment where
he tells him he's his father so that is a
very big.
Where Luke knew a little bit about the force,
but hadn't gotten any more training the reason
the movies were able to get away with that
was because he Yoda still existed an older
wiser master that Luke ago continue his training
with in they've implied that that does not
exist in the new Star Wars films like the
way that the opening title cross if you take
it at its face value Luke is the last of the
Jedi's note is like the last remaining person
on the dark side of the force, even though
he's not sit.
So even though there's probably hollow prawns
there's artifacts that you could probably
dig up there.
The only two masters the go seek out ask questions
and get good answers from you could point
to Moss Cannata and say that she is the Yoda
like figure of episode seven.
I think that was part of the intention because
she seems like she understands a little bit
about the force, but they don't say that she's
force sensitive or that she has any real deep
knowledge of the force.
Just in the way the Donnie Yen's character
believes in the force and seemingly uses it
without totally understanding what's happening
number three the most damning evidence that
Luke my died during episode eight is that
he himself has been searching for the true
purpose of the force, not the truth of the
Jedi taught the Jedi order the Sith teaching
things that were not the original intentions
of the force.
The force has a will of its own people misinterpret
things all the time that seems like with the
writers of producers were telling us with
episode seven Luke and snowcone are both trying
to learn the truth of the force of attain
loss knowledge and become something different
than the force factions before obviously they
didn't explain a lot of that in episode seven
in really clear terms, but you learn a little
bit more about that in the expanded material
something about Snopes past but they also
try to be very ambiguous with those kinds
of details just to allow the other films to
deal with that first and then you get like
all the technical books like Pablo Hidalgo
publishes a lot of technical books.
He also gets a lot of weird complaints from
people, but he only writes those after they
decide what the story of the movies are going
to be.
So on the other side of that there couple
big reasons why they would not kill Luke off
right away one they made you wait to the entire
film just to meet him there was very little
force training or even an explanation for
what was going on.
He didn't even speak just very concerned looks
at the side of Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber.
So even if you haven't been listening to.
The rumors from behind-the-scenes everything
is pointing towards him having a much bigger,
more active bad ass role in OB one had in
the original trilogy think about that Cantina
fight how brutally he cut down pond above
and Cornelius.
It was so much fun to see them in Rogue one,
knowing what would be happening to them.
In short order, but I think will all be getting
a Luke version of what Obi-Wan did during
the course of episode four.
Which is way way cooler so there will be a
lot of things that are similar to Luke's original
training and episode four is like the early
steps into force training that I'll explain
the second why I think that episode eight
will not be a complete retread of the original
trilogy.
The way that people feel like episode seven
was number two next big reason there is no
Yoda to continue race training if Luke dies
presumably she's becoming this new type of
force user and isn't necessarily a Jedi but
is in us.
It is something more complete, you could choose
to think of her as a great Jedi.
That's a whole other video that I should probably
do.
But the reason that Luke was able to finish
his training become a Jedi was because of
Yoda in older wiser master whether or not
Obi-Wan was able to complete his training
this goes back to the rules of being a force
ghost, because if Obi-Wan was a force ghost,
why didn't he just completely straining himself
will one because Yoda was a wiser, more powerful
master.
So of course he would seek out the smartest
person available, but two they also implied
that there are a lot of limitations to being
a force ghost, you can't just hang around
all the time.
Constantly in the way you would need to if
you are training someone to become a Jedi
with Luke became a force ghost during episode
eight he could still talk to Rey that he wouldn't
be able to train her in the same way were
he physically there all the time, I know a
lot of people will point to the idea that
what if Rey were to seek out snowcone eventually
to finish some of her training, there's a
lot of evil Rey theories I even did a video
about her being pulled to the dark side of
the force, but pending any hidden masters
that are hiding out in the galaxy somewhere
there just nobody else to fulfill that role
in the way that Luke Skywalker needs to, so
he just absolutely necessary until she finishes
her training, so number three.
The last reason and probably the simplest
reason for not killing them off right away
is that is just a complete retread of episode
four.
No Luke shows up gives us some training room
dies off goes away never to be seen again
until we learn about force ghost, the problem
with the new films is that you already have
all this information about what's possible.
The way the force works.
So part of the really exciting stuff that
I think were gonna see is in recontextualizing
the force and what is actually possible.
So you will see a lot of new thing.
So even though you know that if Luke dies
he could become a force ghost I think we'll
get some new information and see some new
force abilities that will change the way you
feel about that, everything everyone has said
about episode eight so far is that it is going
to be the most different new saga films you
can imagine the way it's treating character
work.
Not just the force users like Rey and Kylo
Ren, but the supporting cast like thin Poe
Gen. hugs even Captain Phasma they say you
know Captain Phasma one of the standout characters
of episode seven please tell us is more Captain
Phasma and JJ Abrams the producers like oh
yeah there's going to be a lot more Than fast
Mun episode eight.
But I do expect the films to follow like stander
Joseph Campbell heroes journey progression,
but not in the cut-and-paste way that previous
Star Wars movies have done mirroring the old
films so there will be a lot of familiar things
but in reality it will actually be quite different.
The way the plot works out whatever the story
ends up being and then there's this implied
treasure hunt aspect of the movie that they
didn't really address after episode seven
came out, but that they tease with raise flashback
visions where Kylo Ren is trying to track
down some secret artifacts with the nights
of rent here so that something that will play
out over the course of episode a you have
to remember that the force visions that Rey
got were of the past and of things that might
be happening in the future to the really good
metaphor to make is that the force is kind
of like the speed force on the flash TV show
is that it's sort of a nexus of space time
so you can be seeing things from the past
from the future things from alternate realities
depending on the choices that you make the
future is always changing the part of the
fun is in trying to interpret that intent
like what did these actually mean.
So I do not think that they're going to kill
Luke Skywalker off right away but I do think
that of eventually because of the direction
that the Star Wars movies are heading after
the new saga films that he will eventually
die whether or not it's in episode nine or
sometime after that.
But they are talking about doing new saga
films new films with the new characters, even
if they're not going to be doing saga films
anymore.
It will go well past the new trilogy.
So like Rey would come back for some other
spinoff Star Wars movie way way down the road
so the ideas is that the Skywalker family
will no longer be the central focus of Star
Wars films in the way that has in the past,
there will always be Star Wars films that
will always be skywalkers appearing in Star
Wars films that the saga films have always
been about their family in episode eight episode
nine or the last films that are supposed to
be doing that.
So I'll talk more about Rey force training.
You know what the future of this new type
of Jedi is in the Star Wars universe later
this week but please leave all your request
for Star Wars videos in the comments below,
but I'll probably do is I'll be doing a couple
Star Wars videos a week for the next couple
weeks we can make like Fridays of Star Wars
day like a day where I always do a Star Wars
video no matter what's going on.
Congratulations to the latest giveaway winner
Tyrone Beale and he went two IMAX gift certificates.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner the next time
I post a Star Wars video.
So that will be all about Rey's training I'll
probably post on Thursday or Friday.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for all the episode 8 title Easter
eggs and you can click here to listen to Kylo
Ren talk about his character in episode 8.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!